i feel like this moment was special for
me to reconnect myself to a star like
glowing myself again
you know in this industry it's kind of
easy to lose
like the path so right now i'm canadian
again and i'm really
focused of what i want and where i go so
i'm happy
first of all i want to start off with
this hair it is
everything how are you feeling with the
green
blue sort of vibe it's amazing because i
used to do this when i was at school
like i used to have it like green purple
pink
and then i stopped doing it and i was
like all the time like i want to do it
again i want to do it again
and i just had this like yeah i did it
and i'm happy i love it
it looks different i don't know i'm like
enjoying it so much
of course i have to congratulate you
it's such a big week
latin grammy week and you've got cuatro
nominaciones
uh how does that feel for you
no it's amazing you know what like the
grammys are
these are like all of us we're waiting
for it like we dream about
this the our like our life and it's
amazing for me two years ago i came
i won my first grammy as a the new
artist
yeah that year it was crazy i was super
happy i don't know what happened to me
but i forget
everything i was super nervous so i have
this opportunity right now
this year is amazing because uh we have
four nominations in the two major
categories uh
the song of the year and the record of
the year so let's gonna see
what's happened i'm bringing everything
for my performance
for my people celebrating like uh a year
of a lot of success in my career so
nah i'm super happy i'm super excited
i'm very grateful today
and i feel very blessed well you
mentioned it of course you're nominated
not once but twice for record of the
year of course you've got gina and then
you've got tusa
what would it mean to take home the
biggest award of the night
well i don't know but i have all the
time like i'm dreaming
about like i want my music to be the
protagonist
no me no like my personal life just my
music
so for me it's really really important
to have my song
as one of the best song of the year
because that's what i'm talking about
i feel it gets like the respect so
tonight today
i'm feeling like super happy i admire
all the people that is in the same
category and i'm just
enjoying the time and trying to give my
best in my performance to
like you know to take advantage of the
time that i have
yes and i know you're gonna deliver
something epic because every time you
take the stage it's just
so much energy so much electricity so of
course we saw you recently perform
bishop we're curious what does your
performance at the latin grammys look
like
ah it's gonna be you know i think it's
gonna be a surprise it's gonna be a pink
beautiful surprise a really shiny pink
beautiful surprise
um i'm just celebrating that to the
house
one year like we launched the song one
year ago
and yeah let's get celebrated in the
latin grammys
okay so you are performing tusa i am
performing susan
are you performing any other songs is it
going to be a medley or
no you have to keep something for the
surprise i really need to give something
for surprise no i think people is going
to love it like
we put a lot of effort on this
performance like we have thinking
uh all these days on all the details the
clothes
the styling um yeah a lot of girl power
on the stage
and a lot of i don't know power we just
really want to give our fans
a really good moment i really want you
to enjoy it so let's see what's going to
happen but i'm super happy
and super nervous and super anxious like
i'm dying
how are rehearsals going how are you
feeling right now we have been
rehearsing
with the people with the dancer with the
musicians
so right now it's everything like
getting together
i am up to see the stage right now so
yeah i think i'm like the same as you
i'm just nervous
uh i love this so much so i'm super like
i have like a lot of hope to everything
to come the way
we are preparing you know okay god all i
need you to do
are we gonna get a nicki minaj surprise
appearance on stage
is
it has exploded we are obsessed with it
[Music]
talk to me about this song why was it
important for you
to put out yet another empowering anthem
you know this year has been like
kind of weird for everybody weird and
hard
eh but for me it was like an opportunity
to
stop and think about my career and what
i was doing
and i just sit in my like in my bed and
i started watching
all the videos from my beginning to who
i am right now
and i was like so proud or so proud of
what we get and i really wanted to
express that in one song
so i i decided with my team like this
year i'm going alone in all my songs
like i don't want featurings i came from
tusa so i'm going to
like show everybody and show myself that
i can do it by myself so we did ideas
menu and it was a hit
and right now we are with bichota and
bichota is a song about
like a powerful gear and i just want the
girls and everybody to
like feel pretty beautiful powerful
it's about like just believing in
yourself and and have that bad attitude
uh no matter what is around just to have
like the attitude that you're gonna get
it whatever you want
you have spoiled us this year you gave
us ideos mio
you gave us follow you've now given us
pizzotta
what does this next era or next chapter
of carol g
look like are you working on your third
album of course and you know what like
the the next era of carol g is not gonna
be easy believe me
i'm creating something really really
really crazy i'm pushing like a lot
um i really want this album to be as
huge as
i have in my mind because i have been
working so much like i sleep in the
studio doing music
i have been sharing with different
artists learning about different
producers
um putting like i like to produce too so
this album is very special for me i'm
like experimenting new sounds and
different kind of vibes
so i don't know they're going to see a
new look new vibe new music new
uh collaborations yeah it's gonna be
huge we're trying to get
something really really really giant
i i mean you deliver every single time i
don't know how you do
it how you constantly manage to outdo
yourself you bring up collaborations and
you really have done so many amazing
ones in the past
you know i'm with you i want to see that
rihanna collaboration happen but
can you tease who you're working with or
who is like the the dream names that you
have on your list right now
in this album it's the collaboration are
the people that
i always dream to have a collaboration
you know like maybe
i'm gonna have a song like maybe people
doesn't know the artist
i don't want to do just music to uh for
competition or
to get like number one on the radio it
just came
after what i have in my mind and so
that's why i feel so happy
you're a creative genius i cannot wait
to see what you come up with next
it makes me so happy to see you here
smiling um
you look so healthy and you're glowing i
know you opened up earlier this summer
about
contracting coronavirus
what was that experience like and how
are you feeling today
uh that experience gave me like the
conscience
of course because at the first place i
was like
it wondering with different questions
like what is this is this real what is
happening
like i think everybody was the same but
when i got it i i was like hey
i just could like share the message to
the people like hey
this is real uh it it was bad
um i i feel blessed because i know
different people is getting like
different hard experiences
but right now i feel like uh i don't
know like a superhero because i
i get it and i pass it and i feel like
i'm super healthy right now
i know you've always been such a a woman
who who loves your family and and you
always prioritize them
having had proved 19 did it give you any
sort of
new perspective on life or did it teach
you anything
yes of course like i think this year
like my mind
changed like everything like a hundred
siento central my mentality is
completely different
about all the things about the things
that really worth it
about my music about my career about
myself my personal life what i want to
really keep
by myself like i changed a lot of things
in my mind but i
i'm happy it's sad of course but we have
to feel blessed that we have that stop
moment
for everybody like life was we were
living like so fast
yeah it was like kind of i feel like
this moment was special for me
to reconnect myself to a star like
glowing myself again
you know in this industry it's kind of
easy to lose
like the path so right now i'm canadian
again and i'm really
focused of what i want and where i go so
i'm happy
i'm happy and great